hey hello my name is yasser abdu Saha i
am 20 years old
growing up in America has been such a
blessing and you know although in some
ways I D stand out such as you know the
hijab I wear on my head the head
covering there's still so many ways that
I feel so embedded in the fabric that is
you know our culture and that's the
beautiful thing here is that it doesn't
matter where you come from there's
there's so many different people from so
many different places of different
backgrounds and religions but here we're
all one one culture and and it's
beautiful to see people of you know
different areas interacting and being
family being you know one community
you